all right here's the first story from
midi I
561 years in prison Trump fundraising
off of recent indictment with dire
warning you could be thrown in jail for
six lifetimes
so I actually got this email and uh it
says Patriot with crooked Joe's corrupt
doj heading unlawfully indicted yours
truly yet again reports indicate that I
could now face a combined 561 years in
prison from the left's witch hunts six
lifetimes there's only one message
someone can send by trying to throw you
in jail for six lifetimes and that's
fear the fear that if you vote for the
only candidate who puts you first you
two could be harassed indicted and even
arrested by the current Marxist regime
in Washington
all right well so we know about these
indictments but the latest update here
aside from the fact that Trump could be
facing 561 years Alan dershowitz says
conviction of Trump would be overturned
by the Supreme Court
on Tuesday buttons doj filed yet another
indictment this we know following the
announcement lawyer and Harvard
Professor Alan dershowitz sat down with
Fox News Sean Hannity discussed the
former president's legal prospects
suggesting that while he would likely be
convicted the ruling would be overturned
by the Supreme Court quote they claim
that Donald Trump actually believed that
he lost the election that everything he
did was fraudulent that he conspired
with unnamed lawyers to affect the
election you're allowed to challenge
elections indeed the best way to
challenge elections is to come up with a
slate of alternate electors the
government has the burden of proof
Beyond a reasonable doubt that
subjectively Donald Trump actually
believed that he lost the election and
acted contrary to that belief there is
no Smoking Gun there is no one who is
credibly prepared to testify that Donald
Trump said to him I know personally I
lost the election
what they're doing the indictment is
they're taking things where Trump said
like you're crazy to someone as if to
imply that means he really knew that he
did lose the election but more
importantly I'm not so sure how much any
of this procedural stuff matters what
the Democrats have been doing is
effectively just an onslaught of
whatever they can keep firing off at
Donald Trump and it's probably going to
be some kind of Death By A Thousand Cuts
yeah it's impossible not to factor in
the timing here right like you've had
these investigations going what since
the day he was elected like he has been
so uh intensely investigated for the
last effectively eight years and now all
of a sudden on the eve of an election
they they are ready to uh prosecute they
have all of these ideas and in fact they
aren't just going to try it in one Court
they're going to try it three different
times I mean it's sort of bizarre uh
Mike Pence said yesterday you know I'm
gonna wait to review everything but this
is just a distraction from the real
issues under the bus he threw him under
the bus and he's not even at last I
checked he didn't even qualify for the
debates right like I think this shows
you how intensely influential the Trump
campaign is that they are timing Federal
investigations to try and throw off his
his campaign I mean this is one of the
things that comes up when are they going
to have these trials right will it keep
him from basically campaigning and being
with people and instead it'll be in the
headlines where you know they're going
to restrict media access to the court
they're gonna these issues just to try
to slow him down and nothing is working
yeah it's like the same old Tire Trope
they tried this with Russia and kind of
bog him down over and over again and now
they're continuing I just I don't know
at what point will they pull a different
player of their playbook I'm a little
concerned He Is straddling the line like
kind of JFK ish like at what point does
he hop over the line to where the you
know the Deep state does something I
don't know and what are they gonna do I
I don't know it's always a possibility
for any president for a variety of
reasons but I don't think that's the
route they go I think what's more likely
to happen well for one they tried the
rape thing in New York where they're
like he's been convicted by or not
convicted he's been found liable or
something for some 30 year old nonsense
story I just want to stress how
ridiculous and insane the story was and
if you believe it you're oh well if you
claim to believe it you're either lying
or really dumb that Trump went into the
what was the department store like this
murder of good Goodman right yeah yeah
this massive department store and for
some reason nobody was anywhere they
walked in and everyone just vanished
they must have been raptured because
they were gone and then they went into a
dressing room where for some reason the
doors were unlocked and then they went
inside did the deed and left and no one
noticed a sink no one noticed no one
noticed the the King of New York the
most famous guy in the city nobody
noticed him walk into this massive
shopping center it's an insane story but
they've they've tried that I bring that
up because this is what they did to
Julian Assange they made this ridiculous
fake story about first it was like a
condom bro and then molestation then the
media reports it as rape which is all a
lie then they throw it all out and say
yeah that's nonsense we don't care about
that anymore now they're going after him
for Espionage which is also nonsense
but Hillary Clinton was famously quoted
as saying can't we just drone this guy
and then they were like yeah he's in
London so no we can't but this is
typically what they try to do to people
outside of Western Nations inside
they've changed strategies they don't
make a martyr of these people so what do
they do they accuse Julian Assange of
being a rapist so that it sounds really
really awful historically and in the
Press they try that with Trump but it
seems to just bounce off because nobody
cares and nobody believes it anymore
people have already picked their sides
right like you're not you're not going
to convince anybody that hates him that
much that he's that he's a good guy and
you're not going to convince the most
entrenched of his fans that he's
suddenly a bad guy even if even even
many of us fans don't see him as that
good of a guy well it's it's more so
he's a sword
or what did Michael uh what did the um
Michael Moore say a human Molotov
cocktail so when they come out and they
throw all this garbage at Trump to stick
to him and they're like see look how bad
he is they're like oh you're tweeting in
the pot and I think it's hard to
contrast Trump who hypothetically did
something after we demanded he turned
over all of these documents under he's
he's been under Federal scrutiny for
years with the actual reality of the
Biden Administration right like when you
are comparing two things the effects of
inflation on your family and
hypothetical goose chase which actually
is the federal government wasting
taxpayer funds I feel like I'm gonna be
more mad at the federal government
overall it's not helping whatever cause
they think they have so the question is
are they indicting Trump to interfere in
the election
to distract from the Joe Biden
corruption allegations or could it be
that the U.S credit rating was just
downgraded from AAA to double A Plus and
we've had a I I think the highest number
of bankruptcies in the first two
quarters this year in the past since the
past 13 years so something is going
wrong economically inflation is through
the roof I mean just go to the grocery
store buy groceries and and and it's
nuts so there was a viral Tick Tock
where it was like this couple and they
were like it said buying grocers in 2011
and they're like dancing and they have
this big table it's like a hundred
dollars and then it was like buying
groceries today and they're standing
there and there's like five things and
it's the same price so yeah when middle
working class and middle Americans are
right now watching the news and someone
on CNN comes out and says Donald Trump
had classified documents they're like
I'm just trying to buy some beef for my
family dude I don't know I don't know
what you're talking about yeah meanwhile
561 year it's giving very Alexis it's
giving Alex Jones what does he owe now
like two billion dollars or like no was
it a trillion it's like a trillion
dollars like he's he's just going it was
the GP of France wasn't it yeah entire
European you should like it's it's like
they just throw the book at them because
they hate them they understand that the
people that already hate them are going
to continue to hate them they're like oh
good even though they understand that
he's going to file bankruptcy and
whatever's gonna happen and what happens
my thing is like all of this seems like
a politically charged goose chase when
there are like actual child Predators or
you know murderers out there who get
less time yeah it was it was 2.75
trillion that seems the reason that's
the GD the GDP of France I like the idea
Alex Jones must pay us the GDP of France
he's like yep I'm on it it would be
funny if like everybody in France loved
Alex Jones to the point where they were
buying from him and he did make that
much money and we just didn't know about
it and they just asked for his demo
they're like we've got you don't worry
but also like I mean there's j6 people
like they're gonna Rush this trial to
make sure that it happens like right
before the election meanwhile j6 people
no trial no nothing it's it's very like
if you pay close enough attention to
what's going on in the world you
understand just how unfair all of it is
but the average person is getting that
close attention that's what I found
weird about Pence's comments because he
released this statement like right after
the indictment came out being like it
means more talk about January 6 and
other distractions and you want to be
like we should talk about doing sex we
should talk about James sex all the time
because there are people who were
persecuted in a way that no one else has
been and we just let them fall to like
we you shouldn't let them just fall away
side like that's the best thing about
the Trump uh was Trump situation in my
opinion which is that we like continue
to talk about the miscarriage of Justice
at the federal level wasn't it like
literally the day before January 6 Mike
Pence said we're gonna have Congress go
through this and we're going to hear the
evidence and the next day he's like yeah
no I'm not gonna do that I'm willing to
bet that like that night he's in bed
with his wife and there's like a knock
on the door and he's like well who's the
guy who wakes up at two in the morning
and then he comes to the door and
there's a guy in a suit with like Black
sunglasses and then the guy and Mike's
like what's going on and then he just
hands on picture of JFK and then Mike's
like
okay I really just feel like it was just
politically expedient from the time it
wouldn't I don't think anyone needed to
say anything he knew that his role as a
vice president at time was to kind of
tacitly be in this in between spot it
was very clear too and that's why
there's so much rage from the Trump base
against Pence is because they kind of
knew he was talking about both sides of
his mouth and he didn't really mean all
this like him saying that oh we'll look
into this what does that even mean we'll
look into it okay cool like that doesn't
mean much of anything this is a big
component too of the of the suit now
because it's being reported the uh
what's what's a guy's name Smith what's
his name Keith Smith Jake's the is it
Jack Smith Jackson a special account
special prosecutor whatever that he
claimed that uh Pence did not have the
authority to reject electoral votes
which is wrong
he absolutely did until 2022 apparently
there was some revision to the law but
Democrats famously uh brought together
an alternate slate of electors from
Hawaii in 1960. despite the fact that
the state was won by the Republicans the
governor certified the Republican
electors Democrats still convened a
fraudulent slate of electors I say
fraudulent good sir
and uh because if they claim about Trump
and then sent them out and Nixon chose
to ignore as vice president he ignored
the certified electoral votes and said
I'm gonna count the Democrat uncertified
votes anyway well hold on how does the
vice president have the authority to do
that back in 1960 and then lose it well
I suppose Congress could change things
but that's not what happened Mike Pence
did have this Authority Trump's lawyers
were advising him not perfectly but he
had he had some sound uh a policy and
and procedure advice and then Mike Pence
was just like
screw it yeah I'm out it seems crazy to
me also you know like I said before I
don't think he at last I checked he had
not qualified for the debates which
debates our questionable anyways uh the
strangest thing about this is he has to
walk this weird line that's like
well I was part of the Trump
Administration and that's literally why
all of you know who I am except also I
don't really want to be affiliated with
the bad stuff or the more controversial
stuff so I'm going to sort of be the
most politician politician of all times
and try to make everyone happy in which
I will fail the the crazy thing is that
Mike Pence threw Trump under the bus
tweeting that this but basically saying
this man should not be allowed to be
president or whatever it's the inversion
of the fake ramaswamy when Vivek came
out and said we should all come together
and reject these political indictments
and these charges they're trying to
remove Trump you know in an unjust way
that's really amazing so when you when
you say that Mike Pence doesn't qualify
for the debates there's there's it's not
a very difficult question as to why well
it's because he hasn't got enough donors
that's like literally what I'm referring
to yeah nobody wants to give money to a
guy who sucks yeah but that's so
interesting right because theoretically
at one point he thought he was The Heir
Apparent like if Trump got two terms he
would be the next obvious candidate to
win and like he made such a catastrophic
miscalculation and then continue to be
like I think I can do it I think I could
win I think the landscape has changed so
much I said a minute ago that what Mike
Pence was doing was politically
expedient but that was kind of wrong it
was traditionally politically expedient
right and they're still in that mindset
what is now becoming the type of
rhetoric that is becoming actually
politically expedient is things like
what Vivek is is saying like actually
owning it and having bold messaging and
having a legit message I mean I am a
little bit concerned about some of his
messaging and from the past but some but
I I don't know I'm open to see maybe
just change his mind but I mean either
way that is the rhetoric people want
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time